behavior consultant sherry Woodard
prepares to help an international dog
rescuer dr. robot is a human doctor that
was born in Ethiopia but now lives in
the United States he is working to help
people and animals in Ethiopia on a
recent humanitarian mission to Ethiopia
dr. Anton my roba found Hannah and
Hayley nearly dead dr. roba learned they
were once among hundreds of thousands of
starving dogs scavenging for food in the
country's capital Addis Ababa
[Music]
locals caught Hannah and Haley and threw
them into a 30-foot pit the dumping
ground for strays once the animals were
in this situation they couldn't get out
they were trapped a local animal welfare
group estimates as many as 6,000 dogs
died here over two decades dr. roba
thinks Haley and Hannah had gone two
months without clean water and likely
survived off rainwater and the carcasses
of other dogs he quickly organized a
rescue effort dr. Roebuck convinced the
government to seal the cave permanently
then flew Hannah and Haley to the United
States now after seven unsuccessful
months trying to find them homes he's
driving to dog town for help
[Music]
oh he dressed in pink yes you are
it's a dog place ho ho your noses are
gonna be busy Oh what are you doing come
on let's go walk-in go walk-in and
sniffing best friends it would be the
best place for the dogs to be if if we
humans went through what they went
through would be in psychotherapy every
day for the rest of our lives
Hannah and Hayley will be very happy in
Dogtown
it isn't frightening and we could take
steps toward moving into society we can
help them to quickly make progress
without overwhelming them